[Musique]
c'était la médiathèque de sainte marie
que véronique tissandier se prépare à
participer à la 23e édition du concours
national du poi sont magiques un
concours de dictée braille
c'est pour voir si je suis encore devant
nous si je suis nul est bon ben c'est un
peu aussi une manière de sauvegarder le
braille et puis
le papier la culture papier installé
derrière sa machine à écrire le braille
véronique commence à taper la dictée
extraite d'un article de ces news matin
compilation une dictée accessible mais
qui comporte quelques difficultés
notamment dans l'écriture de caractères
spécifiques comme nous l'indiquent marie
pierre d'amours responsable de l'espace
autrement lui à la médiathèque de sainte
marie les termes étaient assez simples
après c'est vrai que je pense que ce
qu'il ya enfin le plus compliqué serait
tout ce qui est en situation souligné
voilà les sites aussi internet donc une
façon de mettre les chiffres donc les
chiffres romains alors là je pense que
ça c'est ce qui est plus compliqué là au
total neuf candidats réunionnais
aveugles ou malvoyants or ont pris part
à ce concours national qui vise à
promouvoir l'écriture braille
[Musique]